So imagine, if you will, you've been dropped into an enchanted forest...
...inhabited by an elderly witch.
She's invited us for dinner and here's what's on the menu.
We're gonna kick things off with a homemade pumpkin punch...
...served in a real fairy tale pumpkin.
Now I'll show you how to make my spooky bug bites...
..which are broiled dates with salty Gorgonzola cheese topped with a crunchy walnut.
Then, it's spider bites created with herbed cheese and black olives.
For our main course, it's a yummy witch's stew...
...made with wild mushrooms, roasted chicken and fresh rosemary.
Then I'll show you my easy cheat for making cheesy corn bread muffins.
Then, one of my favorite recipes for a crunchy fall harvest salad.
And for dessert, it's my wickedly good chocolate fallen cake...
...served with an eerie chocolate whipped cream and spooky meringue mushrooms.